[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans checking back in from the
fireplace hot ones as you guys know Oh
screeching halt but don't worry we keep
talking every single day trying to find
the best safest way to get back to
eating wings with celebrities but in the
meantime here's another Sean tells the
story and this one is all about ghosts
now before we get started let me say
this I was always like skeptic or like
never took the ghost stuff seriously I
remember had this friend Dan puddle sack
in high school his house like back in
the day there was like a tavern
downstairs and he would be like in the
middle of the night I can hear glasses
clanking and I'd be like oh sure sure
you know I'm always blowing off
everybody's ghost stories until the one
day that I moved into a haunted
apartment
so I'm gonna take things back we're in
Chicago I'm living with my buddy Trent a
good time to be alive the apartment was
in Chicago at Wellington for those who
know the area now it was an old
apartment so it would creak it would
grown and more than your average
apartment would and it was something
that we noted and early on were like we
moved into an a haunted apartment and
there'd be times where you know I know
that I left the closet door closed when
I went to work I come back home the
closet doors open creaks groans doors
cabinets flickering lights there was a
lot of weird stuff going on but I could
just kind of dismiss it all as old
apartment old noises whatever but there
are two things that I cannot explain for
the life of me and I'll tell you those
stories now by the way
two things i'm squatching you so we used
to throw these crazy Halloween ragers
and always in the aftermath we'd have
these bowls of candy all over the
apartment and invariably for like the
next 3-4 weeks
we're just thumbing through these bowls
trying to find the pink starburst or the
mini M&Ms or you know the the candies
that people love personally mini
Snickers that's my thing
but you know towards the end there it's
just like a bunch of almond joys and
weird sour things and and stuff that no
one that wants to eat so we'd have to
shuffle through these bowls to find the
one good Reese's Peanut Butter Cup
package left at the bottom of the bowl
so the two of us were always rummaging
through these bowls one day I'm sleeping
and I'm awoken to the sound of a bowl
being rummaged through and the rummaging
is going on so long that I actually sit
up and I think to myself Trent just find
the Lemonheads that you're looking for
you know it was like bothering me and
then I'm like alright well now I'm up
I'll just come hang so I walk over the
door open it up rummaging noise stops as
soon as I open up the door and there's
nothing going on so I'm like what was
that I know you're thinking at home oh
there must be a mouse or something we're
crawling around in the bowl so I go and
inspect it I look in the bowl I shake
around the bowl no mouse alright maybe
my mind's playing tricks on me again so
I put the bowl down go back to sleep put
my head on the pillow and what do I hear
the rummaging noise again
now I'm like in a horror movie I'm like
alright I am going to catch this ghost
so now I get up and I'm slow walking
towards the door
and I'm very quietly reaching for the
doorknob and I'm like I'm gonna rip this
door open and expose this ghost so I
just grabbed the handle rummaging
rummaging rummaging the door open no
rummaging I don't know I mean maybe
there it may be there like a weird the
wind from the air-conditioning of that I
don't know I'm there could be an
explanation for that
but I don't know I don't I can't explain
it that one I can't explain all right
so another night I come home and I walk
in and Trent's entertaining a lady
friend on the couch I say hi to him I
knew her I'd seen her around a couple
times so we chat for a little bit and
I'm like all right guys I'm going to bed
see you guys later I go to bed and and
you know now it's one o'clock in the
morning two o'clock in the morning I
wake up in the middle of the night I got
to take a piss now here's the thing we
lived in a two-bedroom apartment only
one bathroom and you'd have to walk
through the whole apartment to get to
the bathroom haunted apartment is a
weird setup when I walk out of my room
I'm walking down the hallway it's dark
but as I approach the living room I see
that there's some action on the couch
there's like hair big dark hair and it's
moving around there is like these big
windows behind the couch so I could see
the silhouette the shadow of like big
hair and moving around now I start to do
the math quickly and I'm like oh Trent's
hooking up on the couch trans cooking up
with this girl on the couch great Trent
like there's this is the bathroom after
I guess I have to walk like eight inches
away from you guys are hooking up but
I'm trying to pretend like I'm wife and
sleep from my eyes I'm not looking
because once I registered to me what was
going on I'm like I'm just gonna pretend
to play stupid like I don't notice go to
the bathroom get out of there as quick
as I can and go back to bed and I go to
the bathroom I come out again I can feel
action going on and I was like what like
don't they know that I'm right here like
what the [ __ ] son I just boom go back to
my bed boom sleep the rest of the night
I wake up the next morning and you know
I didn't care but I was like dude go to
your room or something you know I was
just goofing him I was just uh just
busting his chops and I'm like hey what
was I what was up with you last night
though I you know I wake up and go to
the bathroom like I have to walk through
the living room just go to your room
next time he's like what are you talking
about I'm like you and the girl he's
like what are you talking about and I
was like I'm the couch last night
when I took a piss had to walk right by
you guys because she didn't stay the
night she left like ten minutes after
you went to bed I don't know all I can
come up with there is haunted apartment
ghosts now if you asked me today do I
believe in ghosts I go yeah but you know
there's still part of me that thinks
about those stories I'm like I'm sure
there's some explanation for it but I
can't explain those two things so I'm
not saying ghosts are real I believe in
ghosts I saw ghosts I'm not saying any
of that I'm saying those are two things
that I cannot explain involving possibly
ghosts and that's the story of ghosts
now once again I have to recommend a
foreign film and since we're talking
about horror creepy scary stuff I'm
gonna recommend outta Germany I believe
hug Azusa did I say that right probably
not if you like the witch it's very much
in that wheelhouse you know I don't like
slow burns I've said that before I don't
like slow burns this for whatever reason
I like that slow burn maybe it was
because it was so beautiful to look at
but if you like the witch if you want
something a little spooky a little
different hag Azusa is the way to go
because I told you so Sean tells the
story about ghosts recommends a movie
about a witch
but here's my explanation to that if I
was to actually see a ghost in real life
like many people have claimed they have
seen they would spend the rest of my
life dedicated but finding this [ __ ]
ghost look I don't understand how people
just bring it up casually in
conversation go oh yeah I saw it ghost
like [ __ ] that if I saw a ghost that's
all I would talk about hey what's going
on hot ones fans this is Sean Evans
checking in to give you the origin story
behind los calientes Rojo so a few
months back we decided to go completely
bizarre world and went dr. Frankenstein
on all of our sauces and and started
mixing and matching the peppers and just
put it out thought it would be a stupid
one-time thing but we accidentally threw
that science experiment created one of
the greatest sauces of all time
Louis calientes Rojo get your bottle at
Heat inist heat nests com2 get a bottle
of Louis calientes Rojo Louis calientes
Rojo accidentally delicious
[Music]